ha sacado a la extrema derecha italiana
del desierto político al tomar control
del país por primera vez desde la caída
de Mussolini en 1943 melón y de 45 años
ha participado activamente en la
política de extrema derecha desde su
adolescencia uniéndose al neofacista
movimiento social italiano a la edad de
15 años la joven habló abiertamente de
su admiración por Mussolini
creo que Mussolini fue un buen político
todo lo que hizo lo hizo por Italia
ascendió rápidamente en la política
convirtiéndose en la parlamentaria más
joven de Italia a los 29 años y en
suministra más joven dos años después
cuando fue nombrada ministra de la
juventud por Silvio berlusconi
en 2012 tras las riñas de la derecha
italiana fundó un nuevo partido los
hermanos de Italia Aunque la perspectiva
de llegar al poder parecía lejana
la señora meloni tiene raíces la extrema
derecha y lidera un partido de derechas
que hace unos años estaba muy alejado de
la idea de gobernar el país y ser el
partido más grande
[Música]
melón y espero su momento la oposición
incluso cuando se formó un gabinete de
unidad nacional el año pasado se las Ha
arreglado para presentarse como una
política antisistema opuesta a la
inmigración y a los derechos de la
comunidad lgbtimás incluso mientras
intentaba suavizar la imagen de su
partido dirán que sois extremistas
racistas dirán que somos fascistas
racistas homófobos
y que no tenemos líderes capaces de
gobernar de gobernar dirás después de
que su coalición de derecha obtuviera
una Clara mayoría en las elecciones del
mes pasado la una vez estridente melón y
ha intentado adoptar un tono más
conciliador prometiendo gobernar para
todos los italianos